and finally new rule well actually
tonight it's not a new rule at all it's
an open letter to a dear friend of mine
Rosanna
first of all pal Congrats on having what
all the haters want more than anything a
big fat hit I yeah I hear you're getting
ready to stick it to the execs at ABC
again it's like 1993 all over that's the
Year politically-incorrect went on the
air on a fledgling Network called Comedy
Central with miniscule ratings you had
the biggest show on TV but you still
came and did mine and when I was down on
my luck a few years before that you put
a guest stars payday in my pocket arch
your back stick out your chest and smack
your lips one of my favorite memories of
you Roseanne is 2010 I made a Christmas
video all about how our real religion
was in Jesus it was materialism this is
our real religion greed Oprah's show
purports to be a lot about spirituality
if it was then wouldn't she tell her
worshipping flock to sit down and stop
losing your [ __ ] over material stuff
yeah some famous people were among those
gathered in my living room to be in the
closing shot but when they saw Oprah was
being critiqued slowly they didn't want
to be seen but not you
you're not afraid of Oprah or anybody
there you are and I will always love you
for it
but now it's 2018 and we have to talk
about Trump because like it or not
you're now the face of the Trump
supporter because you really do speak
for a certain kind of American who knows
they're being screwed by someone they
just don't know who but here's what
you're missing about Trump when he says
he's looking out for the little guy he's
talking about his dick
and as your friends Roseanne I must
remind you of something very important
you're a socialist you've been one for
30 years you said most billionaires are
violent pedophiles you said all of my
ideas are based in socialism how does
that intersect with Trump all his ideas
are based on national socialism
I'm kidding he doesn't have any ideas
but you do you said that you wanted
there to be a maximum wage of a hundred
million dollars and if they're unable to
live on that they should go to
re-education camps and if that doesn't
help then be beheaded
you're not Archie Bunker you're Bernie
Sanders when I travel the country people
ask me about you they're confused
so Roseanne came back to TV but she's
now a Republican it's like if for the
reboot of will and grace will was into
women now or if they brought back cops
and everyone had a shirt on
you had it right back when you said
there is a serious class war going on in
our country a war on poor people by rich
people well
trunk is the guy who during the campaign
said the hedge fund guys are getting
away with murder they have to pay taxes
yeah then one week after the election
when he was dining at the 21 club you
know home to the common man told his
rich friends when he didn't know he was
on camera and did he ever he made their
tax cut permanent and everybody else is
temporary so the top 1% walked away with
83% of the benefits the elite see rails
against on Twitter got billions for ever
and Roseanne Connor got peanuts with an
expiration date
he cut the corporate tax from 35 to 21%
I don't remember the Forgotten American
clamoring for that this is what his fans
have so much trouble seeing the constant
bait and switch
you said you liked Trump because he
talked about jobs so did Hillary so does
every politician you might as well say
he wore a suit but I'll give you one
where he is unique
he said wages were too high our taxes
are too high our wages are too high
everything's too i we have to compete
with other countries
yeah but not Bangladesh he was a
landlord who thought your rent was too
damn low and now he's a president who
thinks your wages are too damn high he
talked tough yeah talk tough to the
pharmaceutical companies he said we're
gonna get drug prices so far lower than
they are now your head will spin is your
head spinning Roseanne because in the
first scene of your new show you and Dan
or trading your meds because you can't
afford all the ones you need because
Trump sold out to big pharma and
sabotaged Obamacare the program designed
exactly for people like the Carter
Family
yes Trump says things he says a lot of
things he never stops saying things but
what he does isn't the solution to your
problems it's the cause of them he's not
a chant champion of a common man he's a
coke brother and rip tailors wig so
here's the deal I get that you were mad
as hell and wanted to throw a monkey
wrench into the whole works
and I won't judge that but if in the
next six months you don't see Trump's
magic starting to work for you
if you're still trading pills and
driving an uber wouldn't the more
realistic plot line for season two be
your disillusionment with Donald Trump
there's no shame in it you saw a miracle
product on TV and you ordered it you
impulse purchase to trump it promised to
drain swamps build walls and make things
great again but you got it home and it
flooded your basement maxed out your
credit cards and dropped your phone in
the toilet all right